hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's no secret Borderlands 3 is one of
my most anticipated games of all time in
fact every single year I get hyped for a
reveal at e3 and every single year I'm
completely let down but guess what it's
that time of year again and I'm getting
hyped again so I thought now's a great
time to look at everything we know about
Borderlands 3 so if you ready let's do
this first let's talk about that name
Borderlands 3 there is absolutely no
guarantee the next Borderlands will have
that title the third installment of the
bottle and series broke that numeric
mold by being named the pre-sequel that
was because chronologically the game was
both a sequel and a prequel to the
events in bottle and two one and two so
hypothetically Borderlands 3 could
actually be called Borderlands off or
even a completely different name in fact
back in 2009 it was reported that
gearbox the dev behind the Badlands
series actively trademarked the term
border world's almost ten years later
that trademark is still in place after
numerous extensions what makes this more
feasible now is that advances in
technology make a game consisting of
multiple planets and real option not
only that but the ending of Borderlands
2 shows us this I never see this key
again it'll be too soon
it's been a fun new alien pieces
what the those vaults you know what that
means
yeah no rest for the wicked
vaults around the solar system bottle
world sounds like the perfect title to
encompass this theory add to this how
gravity worked on the moon in the
pre-sequel and we have the basis of a
huge game with varying gravitational
poles and our styles on each potential
world back at the Game Developers
Conference in 2017 gearboxes Randy
Pitchford demoed some tools and tech
they're using for future games
immediately you'll notice the art style
and know this is the borderlands style
the demo showed how the Unreal Engine
helped his team create games using
complex texture maps and lighting
effects all the way through the
demonstration
Randy both distance the existence of
Borderlands 3 as well as commenting on
how this tech will be used in future
games the depth of the presentation
showed that this was more than a simple
test tool this was heavily developed and
ready to be used again we can go further
into this a character model was used
during that demo and surprisingly Randy
wouldn't let us see her face commenting
cleverly placed the camera here so that
her shoulder pad is including her face
don't worry about the character worry
about the technology right now the
camera in all shots never once gave as a
peek this is strange as if it was a tech
demo
why couldn't we see the character the
easy answer is to jump to conclusions
like me and believe that character is in
an upcoming game and the Internet's
favorite choice for that character none
other than a grown-up a tiny Tina that
was all in fun
one of the most standout personalities
in Borderlands history tiny Tina is the
perfect blend of homicidal maniac and
antihero madness what do you think would
you like tiny Tina to return in a less
tiny format of course let's go further
down the rabbit hole did you ever play
battleborn
no well sadly neither did a lot of
people I've only just given it the time
of day now and although I can understand
why it failed it also had some bloody
great mechanics and story elements it
even had Borderlands references hidden
away everywhere let's look at some of
them now on the walls outside the map
parameters were some graffiti
one in particular reads Promethea with
an A looking mighty similar to the vault
symbol in Borderlands well a little
digging reveals that Promethea was the
home planet where the company appleís
discovered alien technology which they
then reverse engineered and you can
purchase those guns in Borderlands
arguably that could be a throwaway
reference but things were amped up when
audio signals in the game were
deciphered and revealed five pieces of
information that must be linked to the
borderlands series the first revealed
visits Promethea although notice the H
isn't present there the only promise you
I could find was the name of the first
ever cloned horse the H is missing could
be a mistake or maybe a reference to
cloning technology the next audio file
reads children of the vault the one
after that says we are not on Pandora
anymore indicating the destination of
Borderlands one and two will be left in
the past one master date Stannis is not
what she seems those who remember
Borderlands we'll remember Tanis as the
socio phobic scientist with Asperger's
in the first two games in the series she
was our quest giver and trusted
individual throughout each campaign but
now we are told she may be the enemy in
Portland's three oh one more sound file
which tells us blatantly do not open the
vaults emphasizing there is more than
one vault this time if you played God of
War in the last 10 years you probably
developed a decent understanding of
Greek mythology
similarly the borderlands series is
crammed with mythological nods and winks
the planet of Pandora and opening the
vault could be seen as opening Pandora's
box
the Atlas corporation could be linked to
the Titan that
all of the world on their shoulders well
the name prometheus is also a nod to
Greek mythology in Greek myth Prometheus
was a Titan who stole Olympus is fire
and gave it to mankind he was then
sentenced by Zeus to be eaten to death
for every day for eternity make you
throughout what you will
could the borderlands Prometheus be a
planet decimated by fire
the only other Promethea I could find is
from a graphic novel by Alan Moore and
JH Williams the third in which a
futuristic entity named Promethea
embodies a college student and begins
her task to bring the apocalypse to the
world sounds pretty damn epic to me
okay so I've gone a little off the rails
now so let's get this train back on the
tracks and the power of publishers we
all know how reputations are built
around video games Activision and EA in
particular well did you know that
gearbox and rockstar games answer to the
same publisher take-two interactive this
isn't a random fact without reason with
the imminent arrival of Red Dead
Redemption - which will obliterate every
game in its path take two will most
likely move bottle on three out of this
release window this could very well mean
there will be no reveal at e3 for our
beloved vorlons franchise but there are
countless opportunities in other events
further on in the year slowly the
industry is learning about hype and
expectation and good old hype fatigue
take the Enigma of half-life 3 we've
wanted it for years upon years and if it
ever actually arrives it will struggle
to live up to the expectations we set
for it this actually happened against
Borderlands the pre-sequel the height
for the third installment had us
throwing money at the screen but in
retrospect it was quite mediocre
compared to its usual standard due to
our expectations most likely well partly
anyway on the other hand the trend of
quick reveals and releases packs all our
hype into one easy-to-follow window of
information take fallout 4 which was
revealed in June 2015 and released
November the same year in the first 24
hours it went on sale it netted 750
million dollars in a world where we have
hundreds of video games released every
year our attention span has a limit
could bottle and three uses technique to
prevent over hyping their product and
engaging more funds time will tell let's
finish with a wish list of things I
believe would benefit bottle top bottle
and three are
borrow whatever name we receive first I
personally want this like system to
change just in case you're unaware slag
acts like a debuff to enemies which in
turn buffs your other non slug weapons
meaning you'll always need to carry a
slug weapon around in Borderlands 2 even
if you hate them like me the higher
levels demand it for me that felt too
caged in and forced to play a certain
way I really want to use more of the
other 87 bazillion guns instead am I
alone on this one what do you think of
slags do you think of slag weapons so
did you play battle bond I'm guessing
not one thing Borderlands could take
from battleborn
are those melee weapons Borderlands
hasn't invested many options in this
area yet so how about it fancy swinging
a sword in Borderlands 3 what about
character customization I know there was
a little character customization in
Borderlands the masks were interesting
and some costumes were great but there
simply wasn't enough we want our vault
hunters to feel like our creations and
yeah I want a bright pink weapons skin -
how about some PvP would you like a
competitive mode well gearbox have
battleborn which is their attempt at an
online player versus player arena
shooter could this be implemented into
Borderlands 3 another thing we could do
is get the hell off Pandora let me state
I enjoyed Pandora I really did but my
word I am sick of Skaggs and the same
enemy types repeatedly the pre-sequel
introduced the moon with different
gravity which added another element to
the game if the border world's name is
confirmed imagine traveling from planet
to planet a little bit like destiny same
goes for my next point it's time to let
handsome jack go I know he's one of the
greatest villains in video game history
but a new villain would be bloody great
maybe it will be Tanis from the battle
born Easter eggs earlier I could go on
further with this wish list but I think
I should shut my face until the official
reveal as always I'll be stalking in the
comments I'd love to know what you think
about Borderlands 3 start your comment
with Captain buttmunch and I'll do my
best to reply to your thoughts are you
excited for BOTS lunch 3 I am can you
bloody well tell them anyway let's leave
things there but we'll be back as soon
as we have more information I'll see you
soon I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure
plants its dr. chase defendant to stop
her thoughts was all in fun
[Music]